the fashion set are ditching beige in
favor of a buttery new neutral Yes you
heard me correct butter yellow is here
everyone from JW Anderson and Jill
Sandra to Max Mara lueve and Tory Burch
have forecasted the trend the likes of
Givenchy Zimmerman Tove Christopher Kane
and awake mode all showcased a heavy
dose of butter throughout their ultimate
winter 2023 shows back in February while
yellow is not a color that many of us
find easy to wear the softer more muted
and pastel take on the color completely
transforms it and renders it genuinely
universally flattering it's also far
easier to wear than other pastels with
its close lightness to an off-white
shade allowing it to be considered in
neutral and therefore an easy pairing
piece